hey excuse me
need some help let me take a look you
know anything about cars so what did you
say you do well that's a secret I've
never fought is that well because if I
told you you probably would want to see
me who said I was gonna see you again
would you well let's take this place say
it was a bank and instead of that
counter up there that was really a
tellers window and you just walk in real
calm so you walk right up look her in
the eye and you say ma'am this is a
robbery
and you show her the gun like this and
you say but we want you to get hurt cuz
I like you I like you a lot so don't go
breaking my heart okay you're not
serious
[Music]
excuse me I'd like to open up an account
well great what type of account do you
have in not this kind this kind he said
he was armed he had a guy you saw well
he was also sort of a gentleman he was
very polite he seemed like a nice enough
fella look at that is he smile
five states I need three robberies in
two years you think you can catch him
myself
let's hope I get the chance another city
baby another town spent his whole life
locked up except for the times that he
broke out somebody should have told me
well you find something you love follow
and I'm exactly where I'm supposed to be
you're never exactly where you're
supposed to be are you now whenever I
close the door I think is this the last
time I'll ever have a chance to do
whatever that thing was you know what I
do when the door closes
but you about the window is a gamble
baby love it as much the same wherever
sat down the once I said surely there's
an easier way to make a living
any book doing any except I'm not
talking about making a living I'm just
talking about living
[Music]
[Music]
you